yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
why haven't you gotten a vpn yet visit
expressvpn.com
yang
there's one thing somebody said
yesterday and a call i was on that i
thought was really smart was like i
was he was basically somebody who's very
pro-school-opening and he said it's not
that i think that every school should be
open
but i think that schools should be the
first to open and the last to close
and so in there are places in the
country at the moment texas florida
arizona like many places
where basically everything should be
closed like we like
the virus is in a in a place where like
we should not be having beaches and
outdoor dining and indoor dining and
bars and you know like we should be sort
of down to like lock down essential
services
and in those places yeah you also
shouldn't have schools but
in places where you are having in
outdoor dining and indoor dining where
the bars are open
to say then while schools like let's not
open schools
seems like it really misses both the
differences in risks across things
things that schools are a lot less risky
than bars
and also the benefits um at least to you
know some
to kids basically i mean maybe you could
say there are some people who prefer
botched to schools
that's almost certainly true but as a
society i think that i
i think we should i think we could agree
that the social utility
of schools is higher than bars well you
and i can agree yeah i mean let's not
like
you know let's not put words in
everyone's math handlers some people
might not agree with that
but i think we could agree that
[Music]
i'm so thrilled to welcome to yang
speaks
the economist the author uh the person
that makes sense of the world for a lot
of people out there
professor emily oster welcome to the
podcast emily
thank you for having me so i first
became aware of your work
uh a couple of years ago where i'm a
parent
um our kids are about the same age and
there is such like a
strange cloud slash buzz saw of
information
that descends on yours made available to
you when you're first expecting a child
when you first have a child it's very
very
anxiety-inducing and you did so many
people
a service by trying to make sense of it
from the perspective
of a harvard trained economist like a
phd in economics from harvard is like
all right
like what is the real truth about what
you actually should be worried about
when you're expecting a child
when you're starting to raise a child
and that was too much for one book so
you wrote two books on these subjects
one was expecting better which
hopefully that's self-explanatory but
the other one's crib
sheet which uh which i gave crib sheet
to my
sister-in-law uh because i you know
frankly
i think that all parents could use that
book it's like a
um an organizing manual for having
children
thank you thank you for doing that yeah
it's been a it's kind of a weird it's
been kind of a weird ride being
sort of an economics professor who also
has this sideline in
in telling people things about parenting
but it's been uh it's been really fun
i think it's so helpful and necessary
because
uh of really the way you think i mean
again you're
um you're an award-winning economist
and having someone like you actually
just screen all the myths and the
[ __ ]
and then say okay here is the data here
are the facts
on what the real risks are what the
trends are what you should care about
what you shouldn't care about
and so today i would love to to use
that same framework to talk about a
decision that parents are
looking at in the days and weeks ahead
which is
school's reopening schools
yes i hope they're reopening yes some of
them are reopening
and so one thing you did too i just want
to let people know um
is that as soon as covid happened you
got together with
a bunch of other economists and
academics
uh and started an explainer website uh
called covet explained also very
self-explanatory
[Laughter]
some of your work and covet explained i
thought of some of the best anywhere
in part because it's presented uh in lay
speak
where you know it's like if you're a
human being and you want to figure out
okay
uh do i just stop and get uh the ice
cream
from uh the convenience store is that
okay
like am i allowed to socialize with
someone like what should i
and shouldn't i be doing i see all of
these pictures of people
on beaches and then there's like this
implicit like this is a no-no and you're
like wait i thought beaches were all
right
so um so thank you for your work on that
too how did that uh get started
so that started um basically when a
friend of mine connected me to some of
the
uh the sort of key like doctor medical
people who were doing who were working
in this like
really working in the coveted space and
this friend was like look i think that
people are just very confused about
exactly the kind of thing you're saying
so like wait i thought beaches were okay
wait how does this even work anyway like
if i go to the grocery store and someone
else has been there like do i just die
immediately like what you know
like what exactly is is happening and so
uh
and so we sort of got together and took
kind of basically the expertise on the
on the science side
which isn't really my space although i
feel like i'm learning it
um and then the sort of things that that
i think i do well which are like trying
to translate some of these scientific
ideas into
something that is kind of accessible to
a lay person without being dumbed down
right so we're trying to hit a balance
between like it's cool to go to the
beach
and like let me tell you all the details
of of exactly what kind of virus this is
and like you know
show you the crispr map for it like
where is the place in the middle where
people
are sort of understanding the enough
details of the virus so they can kind of
organize their thinking
um but uh but also not so much that it's
overwhelming so that's kind of
that's kind of what we're trying to do
there and i work together with these
doctors to put it together it's been fun
and
interesting i mean fun is not really
quite the right word but but
really really valuable and useful uh so
it because there's so
again a flood of information i i love
uh your approach to these things where
when there's like a fire hose of
information
you know parents get a fire hose of info
about what they're supposed to care
about
the public's been getting a fire hose of
info about covid19 because
like you're like oh there's a new data
point there's a new study and you're
like what do i pay attention to
uh and and so you you take a rigorous
data-driven approach to be like all
right
here's what's not that risky like it
turns out
uh going to that grocery store to get
the ice cream is not that risky as long
as you stay away from people and people
are wearing masks and like
you know you don't have a lengthy
conversation
with the checkout person
um but then there are some other things
that are not so good
uh and and you organize it into pretty
like standard easy to understand rules
where it's like look you know what's not
so good
time indoors like face to face with
people uh
you know you know what's not so bad
outdoors where you tend to have more
space
and uh the virus is is uh harder to get
from someone unless again
you're standing there having a
face-to-face sustained conversation with
them
yeah exactly exactly and now
the more most uh fraught question of the
moment
um what are we going to do about schools
and you know i know you have a personal
stake in this i have a personal stake in
this
you know i'll share for myself so i've
got two uh boys one of whom is autistic
um they're both scheduled to start
school in new york city
in september uh and
uh who knows if that's gonna happen sort
of thing where it's like every parent is
taking it all with like a massive grain
of salt
but you operate as if uh it is happening
and then as a parent uh you have your
own opinion as to okay
is that the right set of decisions and
the number two the big parent decision
is like
do i go along with what these people
decide uh
and if these people decide something
like first who are the people making the
decision and what's the information
they're using
uh and uh what are the facts and the
myths
um and so let's start and this is
something that um
like you and i were joking about uh just
just a little bit ago where
there's like this tone i've seen in some
of the media coverage
where it's like hey some jerks want to
reopen schools
and then the media organizations are
like
casting that as uh a terrible idea
and dangerous and then as usual the
truth lies somewhere in between
um so first can we lay out the case why
frankly kids actually benefit from
school or need school like schools are
uh are like a huge value add on several
levels
yeah i mean i think that there's there's
a sort of kid case and the kind of
economy case for why we have
schools and so i think on the on the
kids side um
one clear thing is that kids learn
better in school so we saw this
you know we i mean that should be sort
of obvious um but even if you sort of if
you look for
data from the spring about kind of what
happened to metrics of learning uh when
kids went remote
you know they they went down a lot uh
kids do not learn as well
uh as well remotely and that is
particularly true for
students who have fewer resources uh and
so that
i mean the the kind of potential
learning losses and the inequality in
those learning losses if we
you know if we are fully online or uh
with kind of no yeah as we were in the
spring the potential losses for the year
are very are very significant so i think
there's just like huge value for kids
and being in school
and it isn't just learning it's also
socialization you know sort of thinking
about like what is your five-year-old
getting
out of out of school yeah part of it is
like they're learning to read they're
learning their letters but part of it is
that they're learning to like operate in
the
operating the world um we don't know
that much about what's gonna happen if
we lose those things but i think we have
a sense that
that they're that they're important and
then there's a sort of separate issue
which is just
schools are the kind of child care that
a lot of people are using
so if we want people to be able to go to
their jobs and
you know participate in the economy
particularly women we need to figure out
something for their kids to be doing
during the day and if that's not school
i don't know what it's
uh what it's going to be but you know i
think people have bristled this idea
that like school is childcare like oh
well school is not child care well
school is definitely child care people
who always travel no it is i mean
it's not a pejorative it's not it's not
meant to be pejorative but it is it is a
thing that people are
using for child care for sure and i
think it's important to recognize that
uh yeah you know and at this extreme end
my wife evelyn
said something because she's always
looking out for um for
kids she said like schools are an abuse
detector where
if you are mistreating your child like
the most
common place people are gonna pick up on
it is when that kid goes to school and
that they have like a bruise or marking
or they seem traumatized
uh so you know like it's it's child care
yes i mean that's just a
factual uh reality but it's also in some
cases even like a safeguard or a haven
and it's a place people get food right i
mean sort of look at like what you know
what happened to food insecurity over
the last
uh you know over this this last period
you know many many more kids who are
going hungry because
you know the school lunch program is
serving you know millions
tens of millions of kids every every day
and and i think part of what's missing
from some of these conversations
a lot of the people having these
conversations are
are it's not they don't care about these
issues but they're not living them right
so we're having this conversation and
like the truth is like if my kids don't
go to school that is going to be
annoying for me
but it is it is not you know there is
there is nothing existential
it's not it's not exercise right exactly
and a lot of the people who are having
these conversations are in that role and
so we're sort of like it's hard to
really visualize
quite how bad this may turn out to be
for
kids who are in a very different
situation
so let's see if we can try and define
the impact of an extended summer slump
because i know when kids go off for the
summer and they're they're not
doing a whole lot that there's some data
around
the fact they forget stuff the fact that
they learn things so let's say we
extended the summer slump
by several months for the spring which
we probably did uh
like do we have any sense of of how and
as a parent
um my kids haven't learned [ __ ] for like
quite some time
you know it's like like they they you
have online school but like
i mean it's not great and uh like
and anyone who's out there first
actually let's unpack that for a moment
because there are
a lot of um like techno optimists
who are like hey um online school
is the future online school the bomb why
do we even send kids to school
like online is the way do we have data
on that aside from my anecdotal
um sense uh that my kids have not been
exactly
like uh you know tearing the world up
over the last number of months
i mean i think the best data i've seen
on this was put out by
actually one of my colleagues who's at
opportunity insights and they use data
from
cern which is an online math platform
that's linked to eureka so it's actually
a platform a lot of schools use
um so it's basically so eureka is like a
standard math curriculum and then cern
is this like
like online portal where you basically
like kids can sort of self learn in
in zern a lot of schools use it in
school and what's really nice about it
is you can track
progress really granularly because
there's like these badges so you can see
like at the end of each lesson like you
do this activity and then you earn a
badge
so you can see like how quickly our kids
learning he's earning these badges
uh and so they they look at sort of what
happens to kids who are enrolled in
schools who are using cern so the school
is using zern before
and after and they can see like what
happens to the number of
badges and in you know schools in high
income districts
the there is some learning laws that
share you know the
like badge earning goes down by like i
don't know 30 percent
uh or something in in schools in
low-income districts and this isn't
low-income kids it's just schools and
low-income districts so
it's going down by about 70 percent oh
my gosh
like yeah so it's basically like people
and now some people have said well
like maybe people are you know have
moved to other i mean this sort of like
technological like
and maybe people move to even better
systems for remote learning
i think my view would be like it seems
like the easiest thing to transition
would be an
online math platform that you are
already using if you ask like what is
the thing that is going to be the most
successful in moving to remote learning
it would be things that are already on
the computer
and so i think that that you know that
gives you a sense i mean if you kind of
translate that up to the whole
year i mean this is like a like an
unbelievably large amount of learning
loss
beyond the summer slump which is already
there yes
so so it sounds like if you had to just
throw in a couple numbers out you could
be like look
um these kids are learning math uh
at thirty to seventy percent less
efficient or slower
rates uh than had been the case when
they were in in-person schools
as like a just a general estimate which
jives with my sense of reality like if
you were to tell me hey their learning
is slowing up by
30 to 70 percent um i would agree uh and
what what you said about uh the social
operating system that kids get in school
so i
i was a very nerdy kid um and so i think
that's mainly what i got
out of school was trying to like traffic
on
like what the heck is going on why is
this kid um you know seem to be
mad at me or whatever like you know like
that kind of interaction
um and for my kids too like when they're
on online learning
uh it's really you know they're not
learning that and they just like wander
off i can actually sense my kids
becoming less uh with it or personable
because they're just not forced to
interact with a whole lot of other
people
and i'm sure parents around the country
are experiencing the same thing
yeah i mean i think that people's you
know it's sort of been been
interesting in a negative way for many
of us to kind of realize the ways that
our kids
deal with this which is mostly not good
um but you know there are sort of kids
like who are super social for whom i
think this has been like
obviously very like hard you know it's
sort of like just very hard
they're moody they're angry they're you
know they're depressed like they just
can't
can't see people and then i think there
are other kids um i think at least one
of my kids a little bit more like this
and maybe this is one of yours where on
the one hand
actually seems fine like they seem
pretty happy but you can sort of
see that there are things about
interacting with other people that
they're starting to like
their like skills that doing are
starting to decay yeah
right and then you know when my kids
went back to camp it's actually like i
did and they were around other kids i
realized how much they had missed that
and how much you know for my
five-year-old like learn like
re-engaging with the question of like
okay what is an appropriate amount of
wrestling
to do with another kid uh you know and
like how am i supposed to like for him
sort of like monitoring his behavior
is is a thing like all five-year-old
boys like we we work on i realized we'd
sort of like
not had any of that um and i think that
you know that is a big piece of
it was a big piece for me of learning in
school um like how do i
deal with other people decay is the
right word i can almost sense my kids
decaying even as they're growing
over this last number of months which is
one reason why uh to me
like this uh trade-off uh with schools
is very real
and what you said about the fact that
it's going to be vulnerable kids with
lower levels of resources that are even
more
prone to uh learning loss
like and if you have kids who are
struggling to begin with and then you
kneecap them by saying hey guess what
we're gonna punch out
you know six months of of school at a
crucial time
uh that's enormous possibly like the
this could be the sort of thing that
ends up impeding the development of a
generation
uh significantly yeah i mean and i think
the other thing
you know people have kind of come people
come back to that and they say well
you know it's not like we're not that
like let's not be so worried about
learning losses like what if kids get
sick what if and we can talk about sort
of the risks to that and
yeah we'll talk about that in a minute
but let's just let's just say like let's
before we sort of put too fine a point
on like like what are the risks of being
in school there are real like
physical risks of not being in school
you talk to you know you
you evelyn your wife's like pointing to
abuse but i think there's even this sort
of like
you know i've talked to somebody who
does some consulting for the new orleans
public school district and she said
basically there are people who've told
her look i'm an essential
worker and like i had to leave my
seven-year-old home alone
because i i like i have no child like i
had no what are they gonna do yeah
and like what am i gonna do and you know
that's not really that's really not good
for kids it's not good for their
learning it's not for at the moment it's
not safe
and then you you can see something
tragic happening to that seven-year-old
and then we're gonna like blame the
parent
that you know right exactly we're gonna
say like you shouldn't well what do they
what did you want them to do
like what choices you give
[Music]
hearing yang speaks we're big fans of
your data being yours the fact is though
every time you surf the web people are
keeping track of you
and that incognito mode does not quite
do what you think it does
pretty much they're still keeping track
of you so how the heck can you truly
protect your data and go anonymous
online you can do
what the companies do use a virtual
private network and if you're going to
use
a vpn we recommend expressvpn
it's number one rated vpn by cnet and
wired who know what they're talking
about
and if you visit our exclusive link
expressvpn.com
yang you can get an extra three months
free on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s
vpn dot com slash yang expressvpn.com
yang to learn more i literally use it to
stream
your podcast videos and music and
netflix at the same time
it works so i i don't know i don't know
how often you use it andrew i use it all
the time it's fantastic
expressvpn.com yang
try it
but in terms of the safety i mean we
talk about the stuff about safety safety
in schools i mean i think
the evidence um is you know
is pretty clear at this point that kids
are less affected i covet than other
groups
it's not that they can't get it it's not
that they can't have serious illness but
it's just
way less common than it is for adults
they're way less likely to get infected
in the first place
they're much less likely to have serious
illness you know there are small number
of pediatric deaths those of course are
tragic
but they're very small uh way below the
pediatric deaths from the flu
in the last you know sort of this last
period it wasn't even a very bad flu
season so
you know this is this is not a disease
which seems to be
very significant for kids based on what
we know
now um so just to to
return to to the learning loss point um
your kids are about the same age as my
kids my kids are turning five and eight
like is there an age at which this
becomes like less of a big deal
um you know where because to me if you
look at young kids then that seems like
a very big deal because it's like a
critical
formative period but then there might be
an age where you're like
like you know if the 15 year old is a
shut-in for a while who cares
um or you could take it all the way up
to frankly college age
uh you know like like uh college is
trying to make similar decisions
um my instinct is that it's more
important for young kids is that
uh correct yeah i think that that's
that's basically everyone's instinct
i think that's that's kind of right um
and people sort of like to draw these
distinctions between kind of elementary
middle high school
college as sort of like four buckets uh
with the idea that elementaries for
elementary school students
you know the in-person learning
component like a face-to-face learning
is just
way like that is the group who benefits
most from face-to-face learning relative
to remote learning and then as you age
it gets sort of easier to move things
um to move things online and i think
that's probably right i mean
some of these points we're making about
vulnerable kids that's going to be true
you know throughout the right kids who
don't have internet uh doesn't you know
you could be great a great high school
student at learning online but if you're
living in a homeless shelter
then your internet is not going to be
good enough to access remote schooling
so i think
there's a kind of like piece of it which
is that basically all
elementary school kids will benefit a
lot from face-to-face learning
that may be true of only a smaller
subset of the
of the older kids and so there's kind of
some balance some balance there
so it sounds like focusing on young kids
makes a lot of sense one because you'd
have
a higher impact on that population but
two my understanding from the data is
that
when you talk about the danger to kids
and their capacity to spread
um it seems like it corresponds to age
where if you have young kids they
themselves don't get sick
and then they don't come and infect you
uh like even if they are exposed yeah
yeah so i think our
sort of increasingly our data points to
both of those things that the youngest
age groups are both
less likely to be infected and much less
likely to transmit
and that older kids are also less likely
to be infected
maybe they do transmit in a way that is
closer to adults i think the jury is
still out on that
a little bit so i think the evidence is
most compelling on on the sort of
youngest
like the elementary school age group and
that that distinctively makes sense to
me because you know some 16 year olds
are
essentially adult sized i mean it's not
like this virus is like ooh you're only
16.
yeah no i mean people have noted there's
like sort of interesting
this is like sort of like when you like
nerd out on this stuff basically there's
this question of like you know
is is there a point at puberty you know
is it is there something that's actually
making kids less susceptible that
sort of like switches a little bit at
puberty or is it just like as you get
bigger kind of you spread the virus more
like is there something else there's
like what exactly is going on this
question of why are kids not affected as
much
is of a lot of research interest because
it isn't true of most respiratory
illnesses so something like the flu is
really like kids and the elderly are the
big affected groups
whereas this just sort of the kids seem
to kind of not be in there
it's yeah um that that is really
interesting
like some um sort of kid immunity which
we're all grateful for i mean at least
like
imagine if it was the reverse um so i i
think
um this discussion around the actual
impact of the lack of
in-person schooling on kids is really
important and informative
and then the other uh other costs that
you pointed out
is the fact that without this sort of
child care they're going to be a lot of
parents making very different decisions
for someone like you you said well this
is like a pain but it's not like going
to be
crippling like you know it just means
that um like me and my husband have to
uh take shifts and do different sorts of
work and
the rest of it but then if you look at
like a single mom like that mom in new
orleans where it's like hey it's me my
seven-year-old
i've got an essential job i can't not
go ordinarily i'd drop my kid off at
school and then pick them up after but
now there's no school
so do we have numbers around how serious
that
impact would be and i sense it's going
to be kind of like
it's going to be enormous if that if you
put uh millions of
uh families in that situation yeah i
mean i think we don't have good
estimates
you know i saw somebody sort of trying
to put together basically some
estimates of this just like the basic
size of the labor market impacts which
is not exactly the same as welfare but
like just sort of thinking about like
what share of households are going to be
in a situation in which
basically somebody has to leave the
labor force that's different from the
question of like what are people going
to do if they really can't leave and
like
you know what are you going to do with
your kids and you know it's not that
cities haven't recognized this so new
york is talking about okay we're going
to open a bunch of child care center you
know we're going to like fund a bunch of
child care centers for
uh for people schools yeah or something
right now that of course has its own set
of sort of like weird complications
which is like a lot of the health advice
to the extent that we do
you know we sort of do think about like
how could we open school safely a lot of
the advice is like okay
keep the kids in pots you know like have
your kid have the like little kids
interact with the same you know 15 like
other kids
but of course if your school plan now is
two days on two days in
another like mixed child care setting uh
you're gonna have now you have not
preserved the pods so it is possible
that like that's actually a sort of
riskier way to do
to do this um
i don't know alternating the the child
between
the school and the child care pod
actually ends up
um creating more exposure than it would
limit
it could i mean i think the the place
that i was thinking about this is you
know
like what if like what are the kinds of
things parents would do if the city is
not
providing this or you know if like if
the school district is not providing
child care what's going to happen you
know the like older woman down the
street who isn't working is going to
open a home daycare
that meets on the like on the off days
when kids are not in school
well that's like actually really
dangerous because that is a high risk
person and now you're
like you know bringing a bunch of kids
who are interacting outside the home
back into this
into this setting so if that's where we
end up that's way worse from a public
health standpoint than
you know having kids in school all the
time that is a fantastic
example and it's fantastic because it
just shows what a real world response
would be
that uh confronts this reality where if
you're a parent and your school
closes you're like oh my gosh what the
heck are we gonna do
and then you have to make really
difficult choices like that mom in new
orleans
who's like i guess i'm leaving the
seven-year-old alone even though that's
a terrible idea
or it'd be like hey grandma uh is uh
opening this like
uh neighborhood daycare and so we're all
gonna pull the kids there even though
grandma
is 68 and has uh you know some
pre-existing conditions diabetes exactly
yeah yeah i mean that's that's what
that's i mean and this is like the sort
of
this is the distinction between the like
the reality
and the kind of ideas that we you know
sort of like we start with the idea like
we want to protect people
but there's like an on the ground like
what is actually going to happen when
you do this
yes i love it and the other big point
you make is like look
there is not like a zero risk
situation uh here where we manage risks
all the time so you have to look and say
what is the harm to this child this
community
this regional economy the the parents
the new health risks versus the health
risks you're foreclosing
by uh not having school
uh and and to me this is a much more
complicated
uh conversation than the like people who
want to bring school back
are like dangerous or something it's
like you know i mean
like instinctively the problem and this
is a point you make and i'd love to go
into this is like look
it may be the right thing to do to
reopen schools for certain kids in
certain places with like certain
circumstances
but you'd want to do it right rather
than willy nilly um
so let's talk about what doing it right
could look like and this is something
you're frustrated by i'm frustrated by
is that there's like a real
abdication of responsibility going on
um on the part of the public where
if you're a community and you say we're
in the midst of a pandemic
school is important like we we have
schools for a reason
like you know they they help
they help structure this entire
community's uh
uh schedules and well-being uh
so what are we missing to try and reopen
it um so you earlier said that there are
a few different things and i've seen the
same thing
where you have schools saying hey we're
going to stagger schedules
we're going to do uh three days a week
or two days a week and then the other
days
your kids at home um you have online
only
um you have uh people going
with a normal schedule uh so what are
the trade-offs between the different
approaches i think most people would
understand what the
online-only trade-offs are it's like
nobody goes to school and we have some
some teachers and i have to say too like
you know that
from what i've seen like the online
curricula are
all over the map um in terms of
uh robustness and efficacy um so saying
we're gonna bring the school online
often is [ __ ] um
so so that there is that reality uh
because
and it's not a total knock in the sense
that it's not like these schools and
classrooms and teachers were set up
to for online teaching i mean literally
it's like i showed up there were
28 second graders uh and then now the
20th second graders are in 28 homes
and i'm like teaching them all day
online like that that's not
reality uh and so then
there is like this uh strange hodgepodge
of approaches
um but if you're a school district and
you're weighing for example what's the
difference in risk between a five-day
school week
and let's say a three-day school week i
mean i think we don't really
i think we don't really know i think the
the question is you know how much
so the reason people have gone to the
three-day school week is or the two or
three or whatever is the
thing is to have fewer people in the
classroom at once
so that relies pretty heavily on the
idea that there's some either
some pod benefit or some social distance
benefit and i think realistically given
how this is going
if you think if you are doing this for
public health reasons it must be that
you think there's something about social
distancing
because i think the pod argument is does
not really
like sort of follow through once you
think about what people are going to be
doing like outside
of their of their days so if you sort of
think the thing is i just can't get 30
kids in this classroom because the kids
need to be physically distant
and so i only can use half of the uh
half of the space
and so when the schools are going to
half time they're bringing in half the
kids monday and wednesday and then the
other half the kids tuesday and thursday
is that the thinking
i mean some of them it's like i don't
know if you've i don't know how much
you've seen about the new york city
public school plans but the new york
city public school plans are like
there's like schools can choose from
like seven different options
there's like a model where it's like
group a comes on monday group b comes on
tuesdays and alternate thursdays group c
comes on wednesday and tuesdays
on alternative i mean it's like like all
over the map in terms of complexity
there's a three the three groups and the
one online model the two groups and the
one online model like
they're this is like in this everything
is like
like totally like wacky um and and so i
think that's that's kind of the idea
that you could then have more space in
the classroom
i personally would have said if you if
you feel like that's important
i would have i would have advocated
opening like doing more of a kind of
prioritized return
where you prioritize younger kids and
vulnerable older kids
and you use like the some of the space
in the classrooms
uh like the high school classrooms for
elementary and you like bring back the
elementary school kids all the time
but nobody seems to be doing that that
what you're suggesting seems to make
sense uh
the where i mean clearly the younger
kids are going to be impacted more
i mean heck half these high school kids
would like jump for joy if
this is what i think we like we're doing
this you know we're doing this at brown
we're going to have like i mean we're
going to try to bring some people back
in person but all these like big lecture
classes are online
people are like oh you know it's too bad
that i have lecture classes have to be
online i'm like are you kidding
these kids it's like their dream is to
take chem 3 30 online
everyone's a whole problem with country
30 is that you have to go to the lecture
like this they don't care so
yeah so uh so it sounds like
a lot of the concern is around uh the
physical layout of classrooms and social
distancing
um now i've got kids who are turning
five and eight
and i have absolutely zero confidence
that they would wear masks all day and
socially distance
because they're kids and kids seem to
want to run around and
laugh and like crash into each other and
breathe into
each other's faces um an awful lot and
imagining that they're going to sit
there with their hands in their laps for
six hours a day
six feet away from each other just seems
like um like a total fantasy to me
uh and so like if i bring my kids back
to school which i very
like right now we're planning on doing
like i i
do not have any expectation that the
teacher is somehow going to maintain
um this distance in the classroom yeah i
mean i think that's i think that's right
i think it's important that we be
realistic about what we can expect
for kids i mean for older kids you could
expect them to wear masks like some of
the time
uh i think it's reasonable to suggested
teachers that teachers were a mess and
in fact i would go beyond that i would
say that basically if we're going to
bring people back to school
you know teachers are are afraid now
whether they you know whether they
should be afraid or not is it like
irrelevant like they are afraid
if we're going to tell the teachers you
need to come back to school i think we
need to classify them as essential
workers
and if we classify them as essential
workers we need to provide them with
like ppe
they need to have surgical masks and i
think it's reasonable to say like
teachers should teach and
you know if they're if they want if they
want to they should teach in surgical
math that's something we can accomplish
i think adults can wear masks um
but for kids yeah i think it's not it's
not realistic to say the only
the only way we can go back is if kids
act like you know adults
but when we look at school reopens in
other countries and i think that this is
this is
sort of the best evidence we we have on
what happens we look at sort of school
reopens in in europe
you know they encourage some social
distancing they have the classrooms be a
little bit less
dense but it isn't like german kids are
that different or french kids are that
different
than american kids you know and so so
i think they it's pretty clear they did
kind of interact with each other and you
see these pictures like kids are on a
playground they're playing
um they're playing together and and you
know they still those places head
it does not look like schools
contributed to spread there wasn't a lot
of spread within
uh within schools not none but but did
not seem to be like there was much
spread spread in schools and so i think
that's
that's sort of encouraging of it even a
kind of realistic approach to reopen
in places where the virus is not totally
out of control
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a really tough time for all of
us we're all struggling
me included you know uh i mean
there are days when things seem
overwhelming when you look up
uh and think how am i going to
necessarily
get through this next period of time so
if you're
having those sorts of feelings you want
to talk to someone and not just your
buddy
or someone who frankly is not
uh actually trained to help you figure
out what's going on with you
i go to better help because they can get
you
a licensed counselor professional
counselor who can talk to you within the
first day
they'll assess your needs and then you
can talk to someone
and hopefully get a rain on some of the
things that you're thinking and feeling
i saw a counselor for the first time
when i was a sophomore in high school
it was awesome then it's awesome now we
could all use help
and better help is a great way to find
someone who will actually help push you
in the right directions and unpack
what's going on inside so many of us
right now
so if you want to join over 1 million
people who are taking charge of their
mental health you can go to betterhelp
dot help.com yang and you'll get a
discount off your first month
of using betterhelp betterhelp.com
[Music]
um i think your point about teachers is
is really important and central where
we're talking about this as if you have
decision makers and then you have kids
and then you have
parents and economic considerations but
if you're a teacher you're thinking wait
a minute and some teachers are older
so if you're a teacher and you're like
wait a minute uh you know
i'm 58 and have asthma or something
along those lines uh
and i feel like it's going to be a real
threat to my health if i go in and teach
25
kids let's let's let's call them seventh
graders like 25 7th graders who are
like around a particular level and
am i being protected in some way
and what you just talked about how
giving teachers ppe
i imagined uh you may know this better
than i do but i imagine it would be very
difficult to teach with the mask
on um like if if you were you know
having to somehow um broadcast your
your class of what's called the
diminished class of like 15
uh seventh graders or whatnot um but
like even when i have exchanges with
people at convenience stores like
sometimes i would take the mask off of
them to understand like
you know like what i'm saying um and so
i actually
found myself thinking it's like is there
some kind of design
um where we could do like maybe it's one
of these like plexus shields or
something
um like if you but but it's it seems
like it'd be tough
um and also you know if i was a teacher
too like the odds of my wearing the mask
all day because even when i go out and
shop
it's like you know like the mask is
somewhat uncomfortable i take it off
it's like an hour
like whatever but if you said hey stand
there for like um you know five hours
then it'd be like
you know i mean i would do it if you
know you know what i mean like so like
i think it would impede their um their
abilities
um but at the same time it seems very
reasonable if you're a teacher who's in
this situation be like
listen like am i just supposed to go and
interact with all these kids who i don't
know where they go like they go home
their their parents could be
um you know getting exposed in various
ways yeah yeah i mean i think there's
like a few
a few things there so one you know one
is i you know it's pretty clear that
we're gonna have to have some
you know system for people sort of in
the teaching staff to do
you know to do this for some people to
teach and some people not
uh and you know i
they're just as you would have systems
for
for you know people to take leaves and
lake leaves and other ways and we're
gonna need to figure out how to fill in
that workforce and
you know people have suggested things
like you know like
can we use some college students like
you know some people on a gap year to
fill in and so sort of like
in different ways not really as teachers
but like is there a role for more
paraprofessional kind of
kind of work like i mean there's maybe
ways to be creative
about this clearly we do not want to
bring people back who are at risk i
think we also want to be realistic with
teachers about what their risk actually
is
so you know for example and that that's
a question for data right so
when sweet so sweden kept their schools
open um
like the whole time and it's not like
sweden liked it so great
um you know they have like a very high
death rate but they never closed
schools uh particularly elementary and
middle schools they did close high
schools
um but in you know and then they they
can look at like what are the you know
what are the infection rates like
do teachers look like they're more
likely to be infected than the general
population the answer is no
actually teachers teachers are not a
high risk uh or not they just kind of
like have about the same infection rate
as everyone else
which is not true of all jobs so for
example being a food service worker or a
or a bus driver in sweden is like very
high risk um
those are like jobs where you know
they're five times the rate of
hospitalization of the
of the kind of general population um but
that's not true of teachers so i think
it's important to kind of telegraph that
like
actually you know this is this may not
be the riskiest thing that you do
and so if you are you know if you are
comfortable going to like eat in
indoors at a restaurant that's actually
probably lower risk
i'm sorry higher risk than uh than
teaching well that that's a very
compelling
set a data and comparison where
if you are a food service worker or bus
driver um you've been deemed essential
and you're going and you know not to say
that i mean to me there should be like
elevated compensation um for a lot of i
agree with that
and these circumstances but it hasn't
been
um like an exodus uh
in in many cases um so if teachers are
truly at
low levels of risk and i also agree and
there's a
the an umbrella to this and i know you
agree with this is that
you know there should be a level of um
opting in opting out like voluntariness
to a lot of this
that to me if you were a 58 year old
teacher with asthma and you were
like look maybe you can explain to me
that my risks are not that high
um but i'd rather just not take that
chance
um you know i have a family of my own
like you know that their various
considerations
then you could say okay like i get it
just in the same way that if there was a
parent who said like you know i don't
care what the school district says i'm
gonna like
homeschool my kids for a year you'd be
like well you know i'm not gonna
begrudge you that
um and so the ques the question really
is whether or not you have the
flexibility and adaptiveness in the
system
where you can differentiate between the
58 year old teacher who does not want to
set foot in that classroom at
all so that some other teacher who's
like i'm actually okay with this like i
miss my kids
um and you know like i i think my risks
are low i'm like
hell and hearty um and one
possibility would be to say like look we
have no problems if you don't want to
teach
um you're going to take like a mild
haircut like this year
like on your salary so there's like some
impact
like you're you know it's not going to
be enormous like you're still just going
to be able to
like be just fine and then for this
other teacher
who's saying hey like i'm excited to go
back to the classroom it's like hey
we're going to give you like a slight
bump
just because we know you're taking on
like a little bit more
and your idea by these paraprofessionals
to me is really important because on the
other side of this you have like
enormous
dislocation in the labor market you have
tons of people that
would love to do some kind of work
including a lot of young people who are
taking gap years
and so this is part of the adaptiveness
but i think you and i are both
relatively um pessimistic about the
level of adaptiveness that many of these
um school districts or institutions have
yeah
yeah i agree i mean i think if you sort
of said like okay you know go
design from scratch everyone is like you
know good actor
and you have like some resources and
you can um you know you can sort of be
creative there's all kinds of
interesting stuff that we could do like
for example
teachers who don't i mean i like i like
your idea very much about sort of moving
the compensation a little bit
i think the other thing that you could
do is sort of say look you know we're
there's gonna be some kids who are not
willing to come back not able to come
back to school because they
their family you know just for whatever
reason they're not coming back to school
and there's some teachers who don't want
to come back to school
okay so let's match those so let's
basically like
sort of run this in a couple of parallel
tracks where there's like some teachers
who are specializing in kind of doing
online stuff with a set of kids who
can't return to the classroom and then
some teachers who are you know in the
classroom with other kids
all kinds of stuff you could do but you
know we're like
but since it seems like all of the
approaches are just like let's take what
we did before and do it at like
40 let's just like take it and do it 40
and but do the same but just 40 of it
and i you know i don't think that that's
i don't think that that's great but i
like you i'm sort of like not optimistic
and it feels like every day
more places are like uh forget it like
let's just go online and
not worry about it which is well well
this is something that too if you're
an administrator you're looking at this
like so let's say i'm the superintendent
of schools
and i've got teachers and potentially
their union looking at me being like hey
fyi like we do not feel like going back
to the classroom
you know and you're looking at them and
say okay like i understand that
and then you have some parents being
like hey i don't feel like going back to
the classroom
uh and you look up and say well like it
may be
easier for me to do like the safe
thing and then just pull the plug on uh
in person schools
because you know like that that seems to
be where a lot of my interests are
heading
um but then there's like a real cost to
obviously the children
uh like the parents who then have to uh
juggle
not even juggle i mean in some cases uh
you know completely
um change their like you know if they
even have the flexibility to do so
uh you know like uh like have someone
like stay out of the workforce entirely
um or take risks with their children
i mean so i think that that's like the
calculation that
a lot of school districts are weighing
right now and you make a point too that
that i think is
um something that we should not be
missing uh is that
if we had our [ __ ] together like we'd be
plowing resources into these schools so
that they can actually
um do things possibly uh in a way that
would make everyone more comfortable
for example i think there was something
where someone estimated that the average
school district would spend 1.8 million
dollars
on sanitary wipes and uh and sanitizer
like if they were to have protocols
around just cleaning stuff all the time
which might help everyone feel safer
like if you had
and it's that you know so that would be
the beginning of something
um but most schools are so cast strapped
that they're not even
meeting their operating needs right now
much less having an extra 1.8 million
dollars in the school budget
for uh for santa wipes um
and the rest of it yeah no i mean i
think it's just like
there's the you know they're lacking
resources and i think that this pres you
know this
pressure that's coming from you know
from teachers yeah to some extent from
unions
uh from from parents i think you know
part of
what's hard is that the most vocal that
there are some people who are very vocal
uh and that tends to be the people in
this space who don't want to
open and you're not hearing a lot from
the parents from the single parents who
like don't have any other child care
options
who are you know because those people
are working
uh so they can pay rent and they don't
have time to like mobilize on facebook
to like complain
which is not like it does not just say
that there aren't like you know valid
valid thinking there but i think that
part of it is like the most vocal people
are getting the most air time and some
of the more vulnerable groups are not
getting that air time because they are
uh because they are do not have time to
be
mobilizing uh and it will exacerbate
um the inequities where if you're
uh affluent and you're like hey no way
are we risking um
our health uh and then you don't have
school for
a semester it's the family that
you know where the kids are gonna be
watching tv all day long
and falling further behind you know
who's just going to end up paying a
bigger price
and you're right that they don't tend to
have as loud a voice in this
yeah yeah i mean we see things like
these like like the like the last three
days have seen a lot of discussion of
the pandemic pods
right where like rich you know rich now
the california is fully online
uh wealthier parents are hiring their
own teachers for their like mini
homeschools now i don't know how much of
this is like apocryphal and how much of
it is really going to happen
uh but it definitely illustrates like
when you have a set of people who are
able to
have their own school and then a set of
people who like
don't have the resources to have their
own school you know we're gonna
we're gonna see growth in the inequality
that's already there
yeah and schools can at least be like uh
helping ease that inequality if if
everything goes ideally
um and to me that's really um
getting missed in a lot of this
conversation uh you know where
uh and reducing schools to content that
you can deliver online also
strikes me as just completely missing
the point
you know i mean and it's something that
uh makes me sad
that uh that we're putting things
out there that are frankly in my mind
leading more schools to close
uh then that probably should be the case
yeah yeah i mean i think it's pretty
clear that there are some i mean so
there's one thing somebody said
yesterday and a call i was on that i
thought was really smart was like i
was he was basically somebody who's very
pro school opening and he said it's not
that i think that every school should be
open
but i think that schools should be the
first to open and the last to close
and so in there are places in the
country at the moment texas florida
arizona like many places
where basically everything should be
closed like we like the viruses
in a place where like we should not be
having beaches and
outdoor dining and indoor dining and
bars and you know like we should be sort
of down to like lockdown essential
services
and in those places yeah you also
shouldn't have schools but
in places where you are having in
outdoor dining and indoor dining where
the bars are open
to say then while schools like let's not
open schools
seems like it really misses both the
differences in risks across things
things that schools are a lot less risky
than bars
and also the benefits um at least to you
know some
to to kids basically i mean maybe you
could say there are some people who
prefer boston schools
that's almost certainly true but as a
society i think that i
i think we should i think we could agree
that the social utility
of schools is higher than bars well you
and i can agree
i mean let's not like you know let's not
put words in everyone's mouth andrew
some people might not agree with that
but i think we could agree that oh even
if i was a young single person and a
frequenter of bars
like if if you came and said hey schools
are bars
um and you'd say look from my
perspective i i
enjoy bars more but like clearly schools
because that person went to a school
like presumably for a number of years
and it got them in position to go to the
bar
go to the bar that's how you get the
money to have a job to go to the bar
exactly yeah and the social skills be
able to go in the bar and not
um you know uh um like uh completely
uh alienate uh yourself from everyone at
the bar
that's true um so i mean i think that's
you know that's
and that's really like at the core i
think that's really where i'm so
frustrated is that we seem like we've
sort of missed the boat on prioritizing
something that's so important and now
we're just sort of like waving our hands
and giving up on it
if you are anything like me the kitchen
is not
like the room that you are most
comfortable with in your home
uh like for me like i had one of these
got like cookbooks for guys
where they said like take your shoes out
of your oven was like the first step
because you were just using it to store
crap and you weren't actually
cooking i thought that was hysterical
but also a little bit too close to the
mark
in my case so if you are like me or
you're
just time starved there's a service
called freshly that will send you
delicious pre-prepared meals it's
healthy
it's tasty you don't need to go to the
grocery store and figure it out they'll
just send you a fully prepared
dinner delivered fresh not frozen right
to your door
it's healthy it's balanced it's got that
goodness like golden oven fried chicken
or springtime risotto or deliciousness
that you didn't have to do
anything except subscribe to freshly so
if that sounds like your cup of tea and
it really ought to
uh freshly is offering our listeners 40
off for their first two orders
at freshly.com yang that's freshly.com
yang for 40 off your first two freshly
orders
yeah it's like yang speaks of buying you
a meal
uh so take a dinner on freshly
freshly.com yang so
i haven't told you this but the stove in
my apartment is busted
and they've given me a hot pan which
doesn't work and randomly like we'll
turn on in the middle of night which is
definitely a fire hazard so
don't use the hot pan don't use broken
stoves if you live in manhattan
or a city that has crappy apartments
order freshly
[Music]
freshly.com
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the reasons why i was so excited
to talk to you and i think
anyone listening to this who wants to
get a sense of
the data around covid around parenting
you should certainly seek out
emily as the preeminent resource
and organizing the world but the
frustration i have is that
is that we just don't seem to be using
data to make
intelligent rigorous balanced decisions
uh and instead it it it descends into
fear and sensationalism pretty quick
um and then if you try and stand in the
the face of fear and sensationalism then
you
want to kill everyone like that like
there's like this
you know it's like actually like i'm not
sure if if that's
you know like like what i'm trying to do
like that's not the way i would have put
it
that you know i think there's some
social benefits to some of the things
and like that there's just a world of
risk
and not to say we should take every risk
um but if there was a place where you're
trying to push the envelope
a bit it would be in my mind schools
particularly for young children
particularly for kids who
school is like like the their path to
to a decent life potentially or like a
decent life because this is one of the
things too
that um and the mom from new orleans
really
puts like the the best picture on it
um but there's like this notion that
like our homes are orderly
like families are orderly and like that
in your kids can be at home or at school
and if schools are risky then they
should be at home
then there's another world where the
homes are just chaos
and madness and stress and like
everything else and the school actually
relatively speaking is a source of order
uh and you know i i think that many
people are
coming at it from the former lens um and
really like the world's much more
complex where like it's like just a
mishmash of situations where there are a
lot of
home situations that um that
like benefit from having the kids
someplace else
for x number of hours uh during the day
like i actually even think like
relationships benefit
um from that because there are a lot of
situations right now where you have like
family members are stuck together
and like the optimal amount of time that
they should spend with each other
is like x hours and instead it's like 5x
and then like everyone's like going nuts
yes i do know about that yeah and this
is from
parents who like you know i'll put
myself in this bucket of worlds like i
think i've got like a
like a highly functional very safe like
uh home environment but even we're like
pulling our hair out and so like
if you wind up with like a stressed out
single parent who's like balancing some
shift
like uh you know it's like like we're
taking it too much from this lens that
like everyone's homes are hunky-dory uh
and that the kid's gonna be perfectly
like safe and cared for it's like oh
they'll miss some learning it's like
actually it might be more fundamental
than that
yeah yeah exactly i mean i think we sort
of we need to switch the conversation a
little bit from like
well this is learning versus deaf into
something that's like a bit more nuanced
that takes you know that thinks about
kind of the other losses associated with
school and also is like a little bit
more realistic about what we're actually
looking at on the risk
so to to end this conversation um as
parents ourselves
when we're being presented with this
decision because
people listening to this some are
parents i'm sure um
so like what are the considerations that
we should have
um when our school says hey guess what i
think my school is on the
three days a week train um uh so
like uh are are there things that i
should be keeping in mind whether i'm
i'm on board
i mean i think i would you know i when
my kids school
you know my school's kid school has said
they're on the five days a week train
we'll see if we
if we get there um and you know i think
the things that i'm going to look for in
their plan which i'm supposed to get
next week
are you know some understanding of kind
of what they're going to do about
you know symptom tracking or mode like
some sense of like how they're gonna pay
attention to what's going on with kids
and keep sick kids home
uh and then you know some sense of what
they're gonna do when there
are cases and so i sort of like to see
schools acknowledge the reality that
like
you know we're in a viral pandemic and
so there are going to be some people
even if there's no transmission in
school we're going to see cases in
schools and so like what's their
reaction going to be
they're both from a safety standpoint
from also from a sort of shutdown
standpoint right if the answer is like
basically
as soon as there's a case we shut the
whole school for two weeks then
you know schools are really not open and
so then i might as well plan
for something for something else um
and so i think those are kind of the
biggest things that i'm um that i'm
looking for and then when you know when
we get to like actually sending them
back
i'm gonna look at what's going on in the
in the area that we are that we are in
um like how are things in rhode island
because i think that gives me a little
bit of a sense of kind of what do we
expect
to the rates to be in the area that were
um
that were in the school well very
reasonable considerations
uh you know i plan on sending my kids um
back to school um with the expectation
that it may not be for
the entire fall because i i think that
to your point that if there is a case uh
then people are going to
shut down pretty quick you know part of
it is like trying to make it so that
even if you do end up with um the virus
in your household that
you don't have people who are high risk
um uh who who may be uh
affected by it so yeah i mean i'm
optimistic
um that hopefully our kids will get some
learning in
um but i also know that um my kids are
among the kids that
would be better prepared prepared and
provided for
uh and then if you look at society-wide
i'm more concerned about
the kids for whom school is truly a
vital haven
um and it's not just oh you miss some
learning then like oh you'll catch up on
it later it's like
i think unfortunately some of this time
will be gone for good
yeah i totally agree well emily is such
a pleasure do you have anything else
that you want to
add for no this is this is great thank
you
hopefully this will be another way to
get um your perspective out there
uh and i am a huge fan of yours and your
work i'm a big fan of yours too so
this is really fun for me i'll probably
return to you um anytime
there's something else complicated out
there that we want to make sense of for
people
that would be that would be great i'm a
i'm a big fan
excellent well say hello to to everyone
um at brown for me and uh likewise
we envy you really i'll tell my wife
about this conversation and she'll be
like
we gotta get there okay gotta get there
all right
all right bye emily hi everybody thank
you for listening in i hope you enjoyed
this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]